I went hunting for big foot for a
television show I did for Scifi.
I called Joe Rogan questions, everything.
And we went looking for bigfoot.
And the more I talk to
these big foot folks,
the more I was convinced none of these
motherfuckers had ever seen bigfoot until
there's one lady that I talked to, one
lady who just did not seem like a liar.
And she was telling me that she saw
something in the woods and it was standing
up and it was tall, like seven,
eight feet tall. And she's like,
why is there a gorilla in the woods?
And then she's like, oh my God,
that's pig foot. And they shed and
it was a Pacific northwest, uh,
outside of a Washington state or in
Washington state, outside of Seattle.
And the woods are so dense up there that
if anything goes 10, 20 feet, it's gone.
The problem with that is that there's
black bears up there and black bear
sometimes stand up on two feet.
They do it all the time.
And if you saw a black foot,
especially a black bear rather,
especially from a distance,
you would think it was a big gorilla
if he was standing up on two feet,
which they do do, especially when
they're trying to see something,
they'll stand up and they'll even walk.
There's a lot of videos of them walking
on two feet and just on the right career
they seen it.
That's crazy.
I could see a big 400% so I think,
I don't think that lady is a liar. I
just don't, she might, let me look.
It might be real.
There might be a few of them left.
There definitely was a thing called
gigantic [inaudible] that lived in Asia.
And the thought is that it came across
the Bering land bridge the same time that
native Americans came across from Asia
and that they came across and you know,
cause they lived in Asia and this,
this gigantic [inaudible]
I think lived as recently,
I think as a hundred thousand
years ago. I think the, the,
the most recent fossils they
have of it, which is, you know,
human beings were alive back then.
And this thing was a six or a,
an eight to 10 foot tall bipedal hominid.
So it was a huge,
huge ape like creature. So check this
out. This is a look at this. Bear
to the craziest shit ever. Bears
walking on two legs. I look at him. Wow.
Like if you saw that, you'd
be like, totally. Yeah.
Yeah. You can just feel like,
oh my God, it's a fuck his pig foot.
Especially if you believe the hype,
your search for big foot out there. Yes.
Or if you're on shrooms. Yeah. Right.
I mean, if you're walking around, if
you're high on mushrooms, you're like,
oh my God, Beth, what's real? Leave that
thing. He's like, hey, how you doing? Oh,
he's got to hurt. Right
foot. That's what that is.
You see his right foot or something wrong
with his right foot sometimes. Yeah.
It looks like he's missing his front.
Pollatos sometimes. Um, you know,
bears will fight with each other and one
barrel bite the other bears foot off or
he could have gotten shot or it could
have broke it off on something. Yeah.
That's crazy. Yeah. He's
missing a foot. So He's,
he's walking around out there like a
gorilla, but everybody else, I was like,
wow, I'm talking to them. They're
like living in make believe world.
Here's another one. Walking around. I
look at him. Wow. That is weird, man.
Those are big as bears to big Asbestos
Hill on two feet. I mean, look,
they look like fucking people,
man.
I think that is a big reason why.
And then they're feeding them.
That is so crazy. Where is that?
That doesn't seem like America.
South Korea. Is it South
Korea? Yeah. Wow. Oh,
so that's one of those wildlife parks
where the animals are all and you're in a
car. Yeah. That's like fake
wildlife. I mean wildlife,
but not really wild.